Wow
[Music]
valiant hearts the Great War is one of
the most human and sensitive games about
war ever released set during World War
one the game is more about the personal
struggles of its characters than it is
about the larger historical details and
political realities of the devastating
conflict the game takes a few small
missteps but it successfully couches
grim truths and a tail with endearing
characters gorgeous art and moments of
jubilance and adventure making its tale
about how war destroys lives accessible
and even appealing to players of all
ages while still giving the war's
tremendous human cost the acknowledgment
it deserves the game begins by making it
clear that this isn't a simple tale of
good versus evil
Carl is a German citizen living in
France with his wife and newborn son but
as the war breaks out
he is forcibly separated from his family
and sent back to Germany where he must
join the war effort meanwhile his
father-in-law Emile is conscripted into
the French forces neither of them are
motivated to enlist or fight rather as
is so often the case in war they are
ordinary people who are swept up in
conflicts beyond their control
over the course of the game you play as
both emil and karl as well as a Belgian
nurse named Anna and an American soldier
named Freddie these characters aren't
traditional action heroes the older emil
for instance has to scramble and
struggle a bit to hoist himself over
obstacles and instead of running and
gunning their way through the game's
side-scrolling stages characters solve a
series of environmental puzzles to
proceed these puzzles are just
challenging enough to be engaging and
satisfying without being so difficult as
to interfere with the story's momentum
you do occasionally have to clobber an
unsuspecting enemy soldier from behind
and you may blast a few planes out of
the sky in one late-game scene but most
of your time is spent helping people
rather than attacking them in this game
you're not a killing machine the war
itself is there's an appropriate feeling
of futility that comes from charging
into battle again and again and seeing
soldiers on both sides fall in droves to
artillery blasts and machine gun fire
it's not all grimness and death
thankfully there are scenes of beauty
too like a sequence that takes place on
a starry night in Paris just as the war
is beginning here you play as the
headstrong and capable Anna a wonderful
character who is determined to do
whatever she can to help people during
the war after performing some quick
automotive repairs you drive down the
city's bustling streets and a joyous
scene during which you avoid cars and
other obstacles in keeping with the
music beautiful moments like this keep
the tone of the game from falling into
monotony and make the devastation of the
games grimmer scenes more impactful not
long after you leave the beauty of Paris
behind you're in the belgian town of eep
where the sky is filled not with
shimmering stars but with toxic gas
reinforcing the fact that lives on one
side aren't worth more or less than
lives on the other Anna rushes to assist
any injured soul she comes across
no matter the uniform he might be
wearing though the mechanics are simple
valiant hearts admirably puts you in a
wonderful variety of situations having
you do everything from cooking a meal
for a high-ranking officer to fighting a
boss battle against a Zeppelin using a
pipe organ as your weapon
no matter what you're doing the game's
art style pulls you in there are always
wonderful details in the background to
give the scenarios life and the designs
of the characters with their eyes
charmingly obscured by their hair endear
you to their struggles the game's
storytelling isn't as cohesive as it
should be for instance there's a jarring
disconnect between the French accented
voice we hear Emil used during gameplay
and the British accented voice that
speaks for him during between level
cutscenes rule has taken away a very
dear friend and on multiple occasions
the game leads you to think that a dire
fate has befallen one or more characters
only to reveal like the bad resolution
of a TV cliffhanger that this wasn't the
case but these are minor blemishes on a
beautiful game that ultimately doesn't
shy away from the fact that great is
just about the last thing any war should
be called
yes decision cannon firing enabled
Freddie and his regiment to reach the
rear
you
[Music]